If you imagine, what would the world look like if everybody took that advice?
Well, people making bicycles would never try to make an airplane.
Stay in your channel. Yeah.
Worst advice you could ever give or ever get is stick to your day
job, stay in your channel, stay in your lane.
And I hear this all the time, especially when I transitioned from cartooning.
And even before that,
when I tried to transition from my cubicle life to cartooning,
not a lot of support,
not a lot of people saw that that that would work out for me.
But if you imagine,
what would the world look like if everybody took that advice? Well,
people making bicycles would never try to make an airplane for one Steve jobs.
Wouldn't be inventing any companies and computers.
So you are right down the lane,
the line and people leaving their lane was all the good stuff.
Um, now I also tell people to build their talent stacks. I call it.
So if you're good at this or a few things, leave,
you lean a little bit and pick up a few other skills. You might get embarrassed,
you might get tired, but boy,
are you going to be happy when you've got combined skills that are practically a
superpower.
Add another one of those things where it just sort of depends a little bit about
how you're wired.
Like some people are just all in on one thing and that is how they can operate
their best.
And some people are a little more designed that they can maybe change careers
more easily, or just learn, learn what their stack is a little bit more easily.
And some people just kind of can't do it.
Or are you saying that's always your job to kind of overcome it?
Yeah. There's certainly a personal difference.
There are some people who just want to stay doing what they're doing and do the
best they can. And if you're tiger woods, that's a great idea. Tell you was,
doesn't also need to know accounting, right? Well, except, well,
maybe it would help him.
Somebody else has made it as managing his money and that's never seen it. Um,
so you can usually tell if you're in that situation. Yeah. I,
I need to just run on this, this horse as long as I can,
but for most of us in just ordinary life, I mean, I,
I can only be a high-end cartoonist because I assembled a bunch of
pretty good skills that anybody could have done. I mean, I draw like a,
you know, a drunken monkey, I like to say, uh,
but it got better over time and I got better tools figured out how to do it. Um,
I didn't have any experience writing humor,
but I figured it out over time and had some business experience. So I had a, uh,
uh, sort of a canvas to write on. So I,
I'm a perfect example,
a bunch of mediocre skills that just work pretty well together.
So I want to back up to something we started with here about your career,
because it does fit sort of lose your thing.
The idea that a guy who I'm guessing you were probably decent at both of your
day jobs, when they told you probably halfway decent,
when you probably not totally, uh, in their election of your duties.
Fair to say, I showed up on time. Okay. You showed up on time.
So you were probably pretty decent at what you did. The idea that they said,
okay, well at two different jobs, you know, diversity, you're a,
you're a ineffective straight white male. Like we're just,
you're running out of room here.
That strikes me is like the worst sort of loser. Think of the day.
Like people have tricked everybody into thinking that that diversity matters.
You know, I surprise people when I tell them that I'm not,
I don't have a feeling about those times that you would expect. I don't feel,
I don't feel like society made a mistake because sometimes you need to use
a hammer and sometimes you need to use the scalpel and you have to know the
difference in those days when there was literally just no diversity in senior
management of two major companies in the Bay area for the newspaper to get on
him about it. I think that's how it happened.
The newspaper got them perfectly appropriate. And for them to say, look, uh,
this is a, this is a sledgehammer situation. And today you're the nail.
I remember thinking of it. It's like,
that's actually a pretty good societal goal. And in fact,
we're much closer to that reality, far better diversity.
I think we're better off. I think it was good.
I just happened to be on the wrong side of the sledgehammer at that.
So while it was bad for me, I don't have, uh,
an activist opinion that it shouldn't have happened because I think it got us to
a better place.
Interesting.
But do you think that part of the problem is that we sort of take a sledgehammer
to everything now? So I don't fully agree with the premise there, but, uh,
but because I just think those things are bad, no matter what it's,
it's just too against the individual from my personal taste, but I'll, I'll,
I'll go with you. Do you think that the problem now is that so much has changed?
We have diversity pretty much everywhere. In many ways, it benefits you.
And I'm not talking about diversity of thought. I'm talking about diversity of,
of your color and gender and the rest of it,
but we're still always hitting everything with a sledgehammer now.
And we don't go in with the, with the sort of softer tools.
I'm very much, um, uh,
I guess my feeling is that if you've got slavery, you need your biggest weapon,
the civil war. If you've got no civil rights,
then you need the civil right movement and marching in the streets smaller than
the nuclear weapon.
And I think we've gotten to the point where you're talking about things like
institutional racism and which, in which case,
my preference is to teach strategy because there does
exist, you know, some amount of bias, et cetera,
that will affect some amount of people. But we're,
we now live in a world where everybody can find a place where the bias works for
them,
for their there's no fortune 500 company who doesn't want to hire a
qualified woman, blackberries and gay LGBTQ,
you name it. They all want them.
If you walk in the door and you you've got the right degree, right. Experience,
and you say, and also you got a job.
So if you're not teaching strategy, instead of worrying about this one place,
you can't get a job leave there.
So how do you, how do you move then if you've succeeded using the hammer,
it's hard to give up that hammer, right? Well.
In the political terms, you know, going big is always good. You know, you,
you want to be AOC. If you're going to be the new politician, it's like,
what's the biggest thing I can say to set everybody's hair on fire.
And then if I need.
To back up, world's ending at 12 years, that's.
Pretty good. Uh, precision wise, pretty good set.
And then you shrink it back as you need it. But it's, you know,
I try not to try not to confuse the, uh,
the hyperbole and the politics with what's the right tool.
Right. Do you think AOC is just, uh,
like some other version of trumps I'm like reverse version of Trump just using
those same things.
She is the real deal. So I,
I identified her early on people who have similar backgrounds,
Mike Cernovich, for example, uh, almost identically the same time we just said,
Oh, watch out for this one. This was before she was AOC.
She didn't even have the AOC name yet. And sure enough, she was a,
she was like a rocket and everybody could see it. Now.
I believe her backstory is that, um, she was selected, um,
in kind of a, almost an American idol.
Yeah. People don't know there are YouTube videos that people can check this out.
They like basically picked her because yeah, she ticked off all the boxes.
Out of all the candidates. She was, she was the strongest one.
So we should not be surprised that she she's performed better than a random
person.
So as a guy though, that likes, or at the very least understands,
Trump's use of persuasion and go big scale back now, watching AOC do it.
And I'm guessing you probably agree with many less of her policies.
Are you worried that that's all politics will become,
or has it already has the ship already say, Oh, is that just where we are now?
I guess. So, first of all.
Well, I would say, um, she, she uses hyperbole the same way Trump did.
So when Trump was running for president and he was talking about, you know,
rounding up 14 million illegals, I just had, that's not gonna happen.
So I never really took that seriously when she says we're going to die in 12
years. I don't really take that seriously,
but are they persuading in the right direction?
Is it good to have tight border security that you can decide to open it up as
much as you need or close it when you need to? Yes.
That would just be a good system,
no matter how many people you decide to let in.
Right? That's like the conversation. That's a separate.
Question. Uh, similar with AOC,
she's got an interest in climate change.
I think the scientists have made a case that CO2 warms things.
I know some people watching this will disagree, but,
but most of the scientists say that.
Now there's certainly questions about the predictions and what's going to happen
to the future. And I would defer there, but she is,
she is moving people in a way that they weren't moved to before.
It probably is an issue where they have movement. Some of the crazy things.
I think she would have to pull back if she were a national candidate.
I think she would. But is there just a general danger?
We don't have to make this about her specifically that if politics just becomes
sort of people throwing out just every theory without really knowing
behind it. So I guess I can't make that not really about her.
Cause I just don't think she's that bright. I mean, I just don't,
I think she's being, you know,
they selected her and now I think she's being manipulated and they took a sort
of pretty girl who just likes getting up there and saying anything. And,
and that, that strikes me is actually dangerous.
Well,
I completely disagree on her intelligence and capability
thought. No, I'm not saying.
The ability is not good. I think she's playing a role.
So the capability is there, but the,
I think the actual intelligence behind it, I don't think is that great.
Maybe I think maybe we're talking about a different type of intelligence here.
Um, certainly she has the political intelligence.
She has a psychological intelligence, social intelligence,
and she's obviously, you know,
knows more than most people about the topics because of her job. But,
uh,
I would say that she's a productive part of the conversation because you need
somebody that's strong on these big issues, like climate change so that,
you know, you, you know, you're getting a good,
a good back and forth and it meets somewhere in the sensible middle.
So I think she's a productive part of the conversation, even when I don't,
I don't agree with it.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop, yelling out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.